hi everyone my name is sai venom and I'm
with the IBM cloud team today let's talk
about multi cloud multi cloud is a cloud
computing approach made up of two or
more cloud environments let's get
started so we've got a public
environment here as well as a private
cloud there is an important distinction
to be made here multi cloud is not
exactly the same thing as hybrid cloud
hybrid cloud implies that your workloads
are working together across multiple
clouds so interoperability and
portability of your workloads multi
cloud doesn't have that same requirement
but we are seeing that you know a lot of
enterprise users and customers are using
multi and hybrid cloud strategy together
I'd say that the growth of containers
and kubernetes technology has really
enabled the growth of multi cloud so
we're seeing almost every big cloud
provider out there providing manage
kubernetes as well as it being used on
Prem and in the private sector to help
modernize legacy applications so why
would you want to use multi cloud and
the strategy for your cloud computing
well there's a number of reasons for one
let's say that you want to hit that big
three 9s number as far as availability
goes multi cloud strategy can help you
hit that by ensuring that you know if
one one of the clouds or one of your
application workloads stops to work you
still have another cloud that's
supporting your applications in addition
you can enable better user experience so
let's say you have users on different
sides of the globe by routing them to
the cloud that's nearest to them you can
ensure lower latency and better user
experiences finally what about specific
integrations to only work on particular
clouds so you have some sensitive
firewall data that you don't want to put
in the public cloud but you need to
build integrations for by taking
advantage of multi cloud approach you
can build workloads on the private side
that can take advantage of that private
sensitive customer data I'd say there's
three major ways and things that you
want to tackle and taking on a multi
cloud strategies and I'm going to
introduce these as three pillars the
first one is going to
automation so to do this and let me
introduce kind of two different types of
users so we've got ops as well as deads
so operations engineers are going to
want to be able to spin up new clusters
as well as manage and kind of see the
different clusters that have been
created so they're going to want to take
advantage of a unified kind of dashboard
to do something like that so we'll have
a control plane here let's say the ops
engineers want to spin up to kubernetes
clusters so they'll essentially figure
out that configuration and then go to
the control panel and tell it to spin up
those clusters at that point you know
they can specify where they want those
clusters to be created let's say they
spin up to kubernetes clusters one in
each of the clouds on the other side
with devs let's say that they've built
out a new application a doctor container
and they're ready to push it so they've
got a container built and they want to
deploy it the same way to both of the
clouds but you know it can be quite
difficult if they didn't have a control
plane to figure out the different
authentications and configurations of
the unique different clouds and kind of
deploy that both times in addition this
really gets in the way of traditional
kind of see ICD and DevOps workflows so
by taking advantage of that control
plane they can spin up that container in
both of the clouds with a single command
say it's application a so I think that
really hits this requirement for
automation with multi cloud the next
kind of requirement that I want to hit
on here
is visibility visibility is very
important for working with multiple
clouds because you know they each have
their own unique dashboards but to have
a single unified way of managing those
things is very important so
for operations engineers by taking
advantage of a single control dashboard
they can have access to a unified kind
of approach and see all of the different
you know clusters that they've spun up
and even drill down deeper and see
things like pods and deployments and
applications across multiple clouds the
last thing I want to touch on the last
pillar is governance these days
regulatory and compliance policies are
becoming increasingly strict and they
differ from geography to geography let's
say that the operations team has a
compliance policy that they want to push
out across all of these clouds so first
they'll have to you know write out that
compliance policy and then you know if
they didn't have access to a control
plane this can be a very kind of
painstaking or rather time-consuming
approach so by taking advantage of the
control plane they can push that
compliance policy across multiple
clusters single command and ensure those
security policies or compliances are
being met I'd say that these are the
three major things that you want to
tackle when taking on a multi cloud
strategy multi cloud has been a growing
focus for us here at IBM if you want to
learn more about our multi cloud
management strategy check out some of
the links in the description below if
you like this video or have any
questions be sure to drop a comment and
subscribe for more videos like this in
the future thank you